when you're wiping a picture oh i'll
tell you another story please
and it has to do with the female butt
okay is the female butt different than
the male butt
i think the female i don't know i've
never examined a male but anyway here's
the thing okay i'm on the surgery floor
women would get hysterectomies okay
i'm
an orderly i'm 22. i don't need training
so they go john you have to give these
women an enema because after a
hysterectomy they fill up with gas okay
all right so
you s this woman was like 30 so whatever
so i go all right hi how are you i know
there we go i have
so i said all right now um just you need
to turn on your side
on your right side and then lift your um
so now she's on her right side so her
left leg is up i go lift your left leg
your knee up to your chest
and then i have the thing what is the
thing i don't know what the thing is a
hot bottle water a hot bottle uh you
know you know uh
water bottle no
a water bottle
no like what do you put a hot water
bottle you put a rubber thing you fill
it with hot water and you you know you
put it on your store and you put it on a
hot compressor no a water bottle a hot
water bottle it's made out of rubber a
butter heating pad like a heating pad
not a heating pad a hot water bottle i
don't know what that is fill it up with
warm water just listen i'm listening but
i don't know
yes you fill it up with warm water and
there's a tube out of it you have to put
the tube in their butt and then the
water goes in and then the water comes
back out and goes back and down the tube
and pulls all the gas so i say line your
side and lift your
left
leg up so i've done this about four
times so i put in the tube and the woman
goes oh
wrong hole
oh no it was in her vagina
so you don't know the difference between
a vagina no
i'm
gonna tell you the whole thing so she
i knew the difference you do she had
what i
define as a low slung vagina
[Laughter]
her
is that tainted
her vagina her vagina was where her
butthole was supposed to be really and
you diagnosed this you and you're only
the orderly wrong hole but the point is
when i put into this wrong hole and then
but
we were both laughing both of you yeah
she was laughing she's about to get a
hysterectomy she's got a hose in her
vagina hey sorry i'm so sorry
i looked at her i saw her butthole and
there's a wrong hole and i go oh it's
higher up
you figured how did she get all these
[ __ ] in their vagina
okay
go ahead
i wrote a hillbilly song go ahead called
oops up the butthole okay go ahead it's
from the 20s all right slamming it
cramming it jamming it
one day i whipped out my dick and it
started to stick it in quick her vagina
was about to slick and oops up the
butthole
my penis is thick as a ham around her
lips with some kind of jam
uh
oh you made me forget
don't eat hot and her lips with some
kind of jam start it again start it
again for the title that's what you
thought when you decided to do a podcast
with your daughter is this what you
thought was going to happen
now here's our meta these are medical
stories
this is another one that i wrote a song
go ahead tell me from the 20s a
hillbilly song called oops of the
butthole okay
slamming it cramming it jamming it
one day i whipped out my dick and
decided to stick it in quick her vagina
was mighty slick-a-doops up the butthole
my penis is thick as a ham and her
vagina decided to cram round her lips
with some kind of jam and doops up the
butthole
whenever i
pull my pants down
my penis ends up in her brown
bed hot chick from carolina decided to
go in from behind her
she had a low slung
vagina
and oops up the butthole accidentally in
the butthole surreptitiously in the
butthole i always accidentally
end up in the butthole in the whole
reserve for poo
talking about the whole full of do
be round
yeah
wow
that's amazing i wish i had a golden
buzzer on this show because you would
move right to the finals with that i
always say that you do better when you
don't have original music but you your
voice is angelic and that was like and
it's based on a true story i've been
working on my inspiring
[Music]
you